foreign
I'd like to know who's in charge today
is it me
is it you
is it someone behind the curtain
my point is we think of leadership as a
role for the few and the rest get to
just lean back now that of course might
be okay for an event like this but I
believe that leadership by the few it's
not going to help us solve the problems
ahead
these problems are complex and coming at
us faster and faster so we really need
to get many Minds together more
resources more capabilities and we need
to do it effectively and sustainably
what if leadership could be for the many
that's scary and for all you leaders out
there thinking it won't work maybe in
some cases it won't but when it does we
have better outcomes and happier people
with everyone leaning in even if just a
bit more
I'm a physicist turned Management
Consultant working with global companies
on strategy artificial intelligence and
digital transformation I'm trained as an
engineer so when I started in this job
everything was new to me
and I have to admit something at work
whenever a task is my idea I do it a bit
better than when it's someone else
telling me
unless of course it's my boss
then I might feel like slowly proving it
doesn't work
being curious and complacent I often ask
why do we do things this way most times
I do find good answers but whenever the
answers seem outdated I try to come up
with new Solutions like with leadership
a typical view of leadership is a
hierarchical organization chart either
you're a leader or you're not most
people are being led not taking lead
communication often flows from top to
bottom along just one line which means
it doesn't match the complexity of
problems which move in several
directions at once
decisions are left to one person the
leader who being only human can become a
bottleneck of speed and scale they can
miss new ideas diverse capabilities and
potential that exist all over the chart
so in a network instead
everyone's in charge and we replace
power of the few with influence of the
many
sure it looks more messy but at Accu
more beautiful
more multi-dimensional more Dynamic more
like nature
I believe this model can help us do more
and be less dependent on each individual
which means it's resilient and progress
is sustainable
to empower many more to lead to move
leadership from the few to the many we
each need to let go of a bit of power
now that's uncomfortable so let's talk
about how
the first thing we can do is remove
labels
now imagine your co-worker Lynn says we
need creative input
and Joe goes let's ask accounting
mm-hmm
said no one ever
but maybe we should
labels take many forms and shapes like
functions titles genders nationalities
educational backgrounds they are
everywhere and help us recognize things
and sometimes we even work hard to get
that label so they are comfortable
but labels come with a high cost of
boxing people in not enabling us to go
outside those boxes
we need to think about diverse skill
sets and perspectives as we set teams
but once we have what if we for a second
forgot who's from marketing or who's the
data scientist
or who's the leader
I've at least been Amazed by surprising
capabilities in our teams
you don't know what you don't know well
you also don't know what others know
accounting might actually have a great
marketing idea
now that we have gotten rid of those
labels I have another uncomfortable idea
for you
share everything
we've learned to share a lot of things
like rides scooters even our homes but
when it comes to work we so often end up
sitting on information and resources for
ourselves
and have you ever thought to yourself I
can't ask that it's too stupid
yeah or maybe you've tried withholding
information thinking it would give you
an advantage
or you know the feeling of had I just
known that I would have done so much
better
let's imagine a team working together on
a green transition strategy and the
following conversation is inspired by
team I was part of
and Amin says he's working on a list of
emission reduction levers he's stuck
asking for help
Isabelle goes do you have this data set
Lisa oh started something similar shall
we combine
Peter another Margaret worked on this
did you meet
this is leadership
not in the hierarchical sense but in the
sense of taking lead for solving a
problem by listing questions and
involving people
leadership is not about giving answers
it is asking the questions
it is daring to show vulnerability
information is power and information is
everything like questions but also data
context emerging insights work in
progress even water cooler conversations
sharing means less one-on-one
communication much more crowdsourcing
and co-creation in the open transparent
space real time
and with more people than you might
naturally think of
wait doesn't that get really messy even
chaotic
well we are used to information overload
already
I'm guessing you don't read everything
on social media and you know quickly how
to navigate your way to what's relevant
to you
and if you catch yourself thinking I can
share that I want you to test again and
ask why
because the upside of sharing everything
is huge we can Leverage The Power of the
crowd much better when we all have
context
it's faster due to less waste in
duplicate work and conflicting and put
in one-on-ones but also because we can
parallelize work and not just work
sequentially
it drives better quality when we capture
ideas day and night and when we
distribute quality assurance across the
full team
but the best of it all we get a greater
ownership through earlier involvement of
people like customers and stakeholders
avoiding that classic show and tell the
one-way presentation
you can probably tell I could go on and
on but there is one more uncomfortable
thing we have to do
be nice to each other
kindness
sure you say but in the moment isn't it
easier throwing someone else under the
bus
and have you tried the opposite of kind
the unkind leader the one who happily
shares blame but not shine
or the pretend kind leader like I know
it's Friday afternoon and I need this by
Monday 8 A.M but don't spend your
weekend on it
kind or unkind becomes especially clear
when someone makes a mistake now take
Sarah she spotted a mistake a quite
significant one now Sarah is brave and
shares that instantly with the full team
wow the replies Barat goes thanks for
sharing that takes courage
some will better now than never
Jenny no mistakes would mean we weren't
moving fast enough
the former leaders in this conversation
they didn't think much about it when
this happened but the team members have
later come back and said that this was a
truly defining moment for the team
culture
they felt safe a sense of growth mindset
and trust that we have each other's back
the team members also encourage each
other whether it's love it spot on or
acute emojis this matters
people so often roll their eyes when we
talk about kindness but even small words
go a long way
this doesn't mean lowering the bar or
avoiding difficult conversation in fact
kindness allows us to take up even
trickier topics
and the results
well good projects deliver on time as
expected
honestly I think we all know projects
that really don't
but by removing labels sharing
everything and being kind we started
seeing a spike
though more bumpy we now get exponential
growth results are much better and
unexpected
like the team I introduced you to people
couldn't believe the impact and
ownership we created in just eight weeks
and we've seen this across many
different problems and very different
desired outcomes
changing how we work we found amazing
results even early on in Pilots 80
percent of our upheaval said they
experienced more value delivered
sixty percent found better individual
sustainability work life balance
and this is an accompany known for high
performing teams
when everyone is a leader it allows us
to do more and do it better
now imagine we took the former leader
out of the team that's in fact what
happened as I went on maternity leave a
few months back
nothing happened the team just went on
even this talk I didn't come up with the
ideas on my own many people did it was
crowdsourced and co-created from day one
distributed leadership is a movement
that goes beyond the traditional leader
people are much more likely to do things
if they feel a sense of ownership and it
was my idea versus being told what to do
we need to create leaders not followers
now none of this is Magic but it won't
happen if traditional leaders block it
we can't afford having anyone sitting
back these days with complex problems
coming at us quickly and constantly
we need to tap into everyone's knowledge
and creativity
labels and hierarchies hiding
information consolidating power being
untinned or pretend kind
that's not going to help us do what we
need to to create a better future
so when I now ask you
who's in charge who's the leader today I
want you all to raise your hands
yes you
thank you
[Applause]